six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty I think we've got time for
maybe one more call before we go to a
break and then we're gonna take more
calls we've got plenty of time today
next we'll go to the to15 area code
caller from to15 hello tell us who you
are
how you doing David my name is Michael
from Philadelphia I have a question yeah
a lot of people a lot of people on the
right as well as the left they call this
Russia investigation with a witch hunt
but they but they also don't sector into
the other things that mother is
investigating like money laundering Mele
Trump's deals with Russian mob as well
as as as well as it was not one other
thing that they was investing I'm not
sure what that was that's what they
think is the witch hunt right they think
it's a witch hunt because some people
want the investigation only to be about
Trump Russia collusion but the way that
these special prosecutors work is once
the investigation starts they are not
limited to just certain paths or areas
of investigation they can follow all
avenues if they believe a crime has been
committed so that the fact that the
investigation has these different
avenues is part of what people believe
is the witch hunt now I happen to
disagree but that's their argument yeah
I disagree well I mean cuz it's like
it's quickly I mean it's clearly been
stated there a lot of things from has
done in this place
it hasn't been within the law as far as
like you know where he's getting money
from how he pays off debts and all that
I mean it's it's very clear that he's
broken the law in the past well he's
been fined in fact is so so there are
there have already been areas where
Donald Trump we know has broken there
was some kind of it was either tax or
there were various payoff they was fine
for I think Pam Bondi in Florida was one
of them and yeah there's I think that
we're all turning to find out some of
what went on but depending on on what
kind of stonewalling and interference
and obstruction takes place we may never
actually get the full story and that's
what's scary is to me Michael right
right okay David I appreciate you
calling I appreciate what you guys do
all right thanks so much really
appreciate the call let's take a quick
break and then we will be back with more
of your calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50